journée difficile où suis-je
tu es mort mais tu as des compétences que nous
voulons donc nous aimerions que tu rejoignes le
département de repos en paix de RIPD ton travail consiste à
attraper Dennis les mauvaises âmes qui ont
échappé au jugement ton nouveau partenaire tu
ne ressembles pas  toi plus
alors à quoi je ressemble vraiment ce vieux
Chinois et toi
eh bien je suppose que tu gagnes Roy pensait à une
mauvaise si vieille cachette parmi les vivants
ouais je ne sais pas quoi d'autre te tirer dessus
entre vraiment debout un wiki nous sommes
avec le ministère de la santé, nous devrions
récupérer mon être mort celui-ci ne traite
pas non je n'ai pas de chance sur votre alors
remarquez que nous sommes assez nerveux ça fait toujours mal
si les morts prennent le dessus c'est tout pour le
monde vivant
eh bien zoomez sur le monde  à la fin,
ne vous tendez pas